[Music]
they're not Abita your man I'm a baby
now remember no scratching I thought he
would never leave do you know what a
sandwich is so you got the job
hmm do my favorite things hamburgers now
if it makes you feel any better I'm
studying these taxes my parents I think
they might just be saving me money 3 out
of 12 is still a respectable number it
is gone the deed is done misspelled
right well give me Lincoln's clothes
I'll change yeah I'm gonna think there's
been a unit for 18 months we got to get
back into our bucket list dude to be
held in Abby's arms you did that tonight
I'm a monster and I just have to deal
with that you deserve this cuz we made a
textme later
you're not a trainer you're a cleaner
wait I was great even right up until he
stopped I love you so much you are my
everything up
you're crushing Jeremy was holding you
back and now you're free you're right
you know I'm gonna delete his texts
there's only four but they're going one
oh what happened last night
are you joking you're Val bitch no mo
FOMO dog congratulations my backpack is
a diaper
I'm a Castro now we remember you cuz
your hair and lipstick like skin you
look exactly alike
I'm not blind and you are officially
disconnected from the co-op plan tonight
Bobby no would you mind doing one last
one that a massive metal bat Abby is a
phenomenal person because she wanted to
give the first edition JonBenet Ramsay
baby
you must have been so scared you're all
alone and that had just happened um
actually he does not mean anything to me
he is a guilty pleasure he's like a joke
I'm not a joke out of it right no no
wait wait this is not a paid job you're
a volunteer I can get the goods if you
hate a diversion I mean you're not the
relationship type right I just want to
make sure you know it's me and not you
Oh realize we're being exclusive okay I
wouldn't want that kind of intimacy
really are witches course we are
which I can accuse witches
he will come who's that I gotta be
aiming it for a heifer that seems
ridiculous we'll take this one day at a
time just say anyway I'll take spaghetti
thanks again for a member of course
obviously that was you you said
disgusting things to me happy for
anniversary you'll always be cheese to
me and me cuz I don't know your
governmentís you found it and sold on
company in one day are we protesting
today Bitcoin because it's yours
but dobot it's paperless here we go oh
my god what bastard
looks like all my roommates are moving
out I understand you got too much love
just one person I was just thinking
would it be illegal or whatever if I if
I got your phone number
go get you never getting that we could
leave our bags down today I'm really
getting this idea just gonna be like so
good it works so long it's gonna be ok
[Music]